care for more overpowered main
characters I've got your back with
volume two of the top ten overpowered
main characters in this list we once
again take a look at some of the main
characters that seem too strong for
their own good whether it be having a
whole lot of insane powers plot armor or
just plain old strength now I don't want
to keep you waiting so let's take a look
at another set of 10 overpowered main
characters but take notes the characters
are overpowered in relation to the power
levels of their own series
[Music]
shocked
we start off this list with ECOA oh boy
we're off to a good start with a light
novel protagonist with the main
character of proto no game no life just
like the protagonist of no game no life
he always starts off as insignificant
then he gets transported into a world of
games now what do you do when you first
get transported into another world
challenge a water god of beat him
without breaking a sweat
let's take a deeper look at his feats
now shall we in the anime he's deflected
laticious Lance stop meiosis sword
destroyed our goal the Gorgon and
defeated waser in divine mode all in
just ten episodes to add to that he has
the power to destroy gifts is there
anything he can't do next we have Kirito
Kirito is actually pretty tame when it
comes to his arsenal a plain teenager in
real life inside a game is where he
shines lots of grinding and time on
video games made him a master of ER to
the point that he was given the
extremely unique dual wield skill in his
time in iron crowd he can also adapt
very well to new games he's thrust into
have you ever seen his beginner moves in
GGO or how easily he can adapt to the
underworld and Alice's ation now just
wait until he goes all-out in Alice's
Asian part twos climax the anime even
expanded his resume of feats
we have anime only scenes that imply he
came back from the dead in iron crab and
even that scene that suggests he only
lost to Yuki because of the time limit
then again as I said Kyoto is pretty
tame compared to what we have coming up
so sit tight and prepare for more
craziness
next up it's Rimmer ooh tempest first
let me advise you to go to Rimmer ooze
wiki page to look at his powers and
abilities have you seen it yep that sure
is a handful of powers and abilities
befitting for the ruler of monsters His
grace age pay nullification and predator
skills alone provide him limitless
potential being a slime he can also
regenerate his body making him nya and
killable actually scratch that is it
even possible to kill him I mean I doubt
it in the world of tenser Oh Rimmer
who's practically an unparalleled God
his powers are unmatched he has
something for every occasion if that
doesn't scream over power to you I don't
know what does waltzing into the seventh
spot is accelerator in a city full of
powerful beings it's tough to climb to
the summit but with a power like vector
deflection who could compare to
accelerator he's not the number one
ranked espera in Academy City for
nothing you know
unlike Rimmer ooh accelerator doesn't
have a plethora of powers to work with
when you look at the rest of the Esper's
and Index accelerators base power seems
less flashy at first glance what he has
is complete control over vectors and the
ability to reflect attacks meaning any
physical fighter pretty much Auto loses
against him you either die from his
touch of death will find yourself
getting blown up by your own strength
he's so overpowered that he had to be
nerfed early on in index and he's still
stronger than everyone else at that
point
medaka core economy is next on the list
being an over-the-top parody or
deconstruction of the shown in genre it
shouldn't come as a surprise that
madara's boxes main character medaka
Kurumi finds herself on the list of
overpowered main characters let's go
over a powers now shall we've enhanced
combat skills super human physiology
among others let's not even get started
with her abnormality the end what does
it do in short anything you can do she
can do better
medaka takes other powers and uses them
to better affect talk about rubbing salt
in the wound you know seeing a stronger
version of your own powers being used
against you the only thing that limits
it is that she can't copy the original
users physical conditions and status
duders to be buried earlier than their
sanity to shoot
instead of crazy reality rewriting
powers or countless laser beams headed
your way how about a master strategist
Lelouch is the embodiment of the master
tactician character that became popular
in the mid to late 2000s think like
Yagami but on steroids Lelouch has no
peers when it comes to the Battle of
braids he always has the upper hand with
his strategies his plans are practically
flawless and he can single-handedly turn
the tide of battle with his tactical
supremacy his Geass is just the icing on
the cake yeah what else could we give a
master tactician to make him more
overpowered I know give him godlike
control over people granted this power
has limits but it's still an overpowered
ability to have the scary thing about
the gears isn't the forefront of his
attacks Lelouch often lets his superior
intellect do most of the heavy lifting
and merely has his magical eye as a
trump card God have mercy on anyone who
tries to take him on in a battle of wits
now did that convince you to watch Code
Geass good
come closer
[Music]
remember gold experience Requiem a
member of our previous list of top anime
power-ups then it's no surprise that its
wielder Giorno finds his way to this
list in terms of physical abilities
Dianna probably isn't your best bet
among the whole lot of Jojo characters
his main claim to being an overpowered
character comes in the form of his stand
it is base form gold experience already
has powers connected to life the ability
to give life to inanimate objects in
regeneration the wild ride begins once
gold experience evolves into gold
experience Requiem we already talked
about gold experience Requiem in a
previous video but in addition to those
abilities it basically carries the
ability to refer everything into a state
of zero Oh understand acts as an
independent fully sentient entity now do
you or no definitely not an opponent to
be trifled with
[Music]
[Music]
yukimaru from Dora row is third on our
list he may not look like it but ya
komaru is a man fighting with a handicap
having his body stolen by demons as a
baby he settles for a prosthetic body
given to him by doctor jukai the
handicapped hero sets off on a journey
to kill demons in a quest to finally
regained the body he lost wait did I
just say handicapped first off ya komaru
knows no pain thanks to his prosthetic
body he's virtually invincible in short
and in addition to that his fake body
provides enhanced senses sword
proficiency soul manipulation telepathy
I mean the list just goes on needless to
say his body is his weapon no demon
stands a chance against this powerful
Ronin invincibility psychic senses and a
mastery of the sword how are you
supposed to defeat that Vulcan on am i a
psychic soon turn or doc sorry next up
we have psyche from the disastrous life
of psyche kay now for something a bit
different
unlike other characters from this list
psyche is not part of an action anime
it's the only anime on this list that's
probably seen as a slice-of-life comedy
and the most unique one you see it to
most people powers are blessing that
anyone would die for but that's not the
case for psyche some of its abilities
include telekinesis levitation x-ray
vision clairvoyance astral projection
pyrokinesis mind-control psychometrics
and invisibility see but the thing is he
finds the assortment of powers nothing
more than a bother and not only that his
power attracts the attention of many
giving him great difficulty in getting
the quiet and peaceful life the heat oh
so desires so what happens when a person
like this gets handed a gift for curse
of such crazy abilities well watch the
disastrous life of psyche kay to find
out
now here's a unique case for this entry
we take a look at the main character of
a Korean series which has an OVA and an
ona by the way and will soon have a full
anime adaptation right looks strong at
first glance he's one of those cool
brooding characters that find off and
there the traditional hero's greatest
rival with that we take a look at his
pool of powers so what do we have here
them psychic abilities enhanced physical
abilities control over the souls energy
his signature blood rain you name it
he's got it in the knobblies universe
rised the pinnacle of power being the
one true knobblies he's the most
powerful Noble in existence that is the
avatar of strength the only thing that
serves as his limiter is his life how
long till the inevitable power creep
sets in anyone because the way early
knobbly says by myself I'm having
difficulty finding a way to rain rise
power levels in without involving his
own limitations well well well that's a
lot of overpowered main characters there
isn't it that'll do it for now for those
who also watched the first video which
of the top two ten overpowered character
rosters would win if they were to go
head to head I'd love to hear your
feedback on that one for more content
like this feel free to like subscribe
and hit the bell button I'd love to see
you stay for the ride in the next video
[Music]
[Music]